if you are someone that deals with a
crippling sense of insufficiency your
ability to Discount any good thoughts
you have in your mind is going to be so
strong if you try and lead with
positivity first I need to think it wish
it believe it and I will achieve it your
set point of negativity is going to just
Crush that into the ground I'm speaking
from personal experience right as the
guy that was chronically unconfident and
still has the Imposter syndrome that
does creep in you have to start with
action it needs to be okay what would
have had to have happened in a week's
time for me to look back on that week
and find pride in myself stop breaking
promises to yourself when you say I'm
going to wake up tomorrow at 7am and
when the option comes to hit the snooze
button don't do it there's one win that
you've got for the day that's action
right you want to leave your job and
become a writer okay can you commit to
writing one blog post on sub stack per
week for the next three weeks that would
make you feel like less of a loser if
you did that action has to come first